[Música]
el programa de las Naciones Unidas para
el desarrollo advirtió que sin la
continuidad de la educación de las niñas
y la capacidad de trabajo de las mujeres
las perspectivas de recuperación de
Afganistán seguirán siendo sombrías esto
sumado a la pérdida de apoyo
internacional que sería una consecuencia
de la crisis de inflación en el mundo
pero también un efecto de la percepción
de Afganistán cada vez más como un país
que pasa por alto los Derechos Humanos
pese a todos los derechos de las
ciudadanas no han parado de retroceder
Mónica Bernabé periodista del diario ara
ha estado en Afganistán hace dos semanas
y vivió durante casi ocho años en el
país Mónica Gracias por estar con
nosotros hoy en France 24 las mujeres en
Afganistán son violentadas y lentamente
eliminadas de la vida pública en menos
de dos años desde la salida de Estados
Unidos ya no son bienvenidas en los
Colegios ni en las universidades y su
participación en los ambientes laborales
es cada vez más limitada que puede pasar
Qué pasará en un país que desaparece a
sus mujeres de la sociedad
Bueno pues no puede pasar nada nada
bueno no
un país que no puede pues eso no que las
niñas y las jóvenes no pueden estudiar
Porque en la actualidad las niñas
solamente pueden estudiar Hasta sexto de
primaria hasta que tienen 12 años y
después son expulsadas de los centros
educativos y también desde este curso
escolar las jóvenes tampoco pueden ir a
la universidad No eso pues plantea
incógnitas de qué va a ocurrir por
ejemplo en los hospitales no porque
actualmente solamente las doctoras
mujeres pueden atender a mujeres a
pacientes mujeres por tanto que ocurrirá
si no hay ni tan siquiera un relevo para
el sector sanitario
claro Mónica y quedan a un mecanismos
para verificar de alguna manera la
situación de Derechos Humanos en
Afganistán
Bueno hay que recordar que en Afganistán
no queda ninguna embajada occidental
solamente Japón es el único país
occidental que tiene que tienen bajada y
que actualmente sí que hay la presencia
de las Naciones Unidas pero que en
cierta manera también se encuentran
atadas de pies y manos hay que recordar
que los recintos de las Naciones Unidas
actualmente son vigilados y protegidos
por los propios talibanes
realmente las situaciones muy difícil es
todas estas restricciones que los
talibanes cada vez están poniendo más
contra las mujeres También tienen como
objetivo presionar a la comunidad
internacional para que reconozca al
régimen talibán como el gobierno
legítimo de afganista no es decir se
está utilizando a las mujeres como como
moneda de cambio no y hay que ver dónde
llegar a esta situación estábamos
hablando de las amenazas de las Naciones
Unidas
de no seguir dando ayuda a Afganistán
sino mejorar la situación de las mujeres
nos hablabas tú precisamente de ese
chantaje que los talibanes hacen También
hacia la comunidad internacional pero
aunque se cumplan las amenazas de las
Naciones Unidas también de otros actores
internacionales solucionarían estos
chantajes la situación actual de las
mujeres en Afganistán
las unidades sinceramente Espero y creo
que no se va a hacer realidad porque
también es una manera de presionar al
régimen talibáns las Naciones Unidas se
van de Afganistán es que ya la población
afgana queda totalmente a su suerte no
yo creo que la comunidad internacional
tendría que reflexionar Qué vamos a
hacer no también por la responsabilidad
que tienen los países de la otan después
de presencia en el país durante durante
20 años no Yo creo que ahora actualmente
ningún país está dispuesto a hacer nada
por Afganistán por tanto habrá que
lidiar con el régimen que hay en la
actualidad y que según parece va a estar
tiempo en el poder no
es decir negociar con ellos para
intentar salvaguardar el máximo los
derechos de la población y sobre todo
los derechos de las mujeres también debo
decir que en la actualidad Yo he estado
recientemente en Afganistán
he estado trabajando sin de prensa los
talibanes no dan permiso de prensa en la
actualidad a periodistas extranjeros no
les interesa que se hable de Afganistán
no les interesa que haya información y
ese silencio informativo Pues solamente
puede tener como consecuencia una mayor
impunidad y una mayor vulneración de los
derechos de la población afgana claro
Mónica y ahora precisamente hablando de
tu viaje Afganistán cómo has visto que
es la situación del activismo si queda
cierto activismo Cómo se puede luchar
desde dentro de Afganistán teniendo en
cuenta que quizás la ayuda externa como
venimos hablando cada vez es menor
Pues el activismo la verdad es que cada
vez tiene más dificultades en primer
lugar porque se tiene que enfrentar a un
régimen completamente armado con armas
que les facilitaron los países de la
otan a las fuerzas afganas y que ahora
se los han quedado los talibanes eso Por
una parte
que detiene a cualquier de activista que
pretenda presentar resistencia Y que
además aunque se hayan protestas esas
protestas no aparecen en ninguna parte
porque no hay casi periodistas
extranjeros sobre el terreno y los
periodistas locales se intentan informar
de esa resistencia son detenidos no por
tanto realmente
esperar que los activistas desde dentro
del país puedan impulsar un cambio es
muy difícil
Mónica entonces podríamos decir que
quizás los países occidentales están
dejando de nuevo a su Merced a las
mujeres y al pueblo en general de
Afganistán
están dejando de nuevo a su Merced el
pueblo de Afganistán Pero además yo
también reflexionaría qué va a ocurrir
con Afganistán
el régimen talibán Es un régimen
totalmente radical
fanatismo religioso
total hay que recordar que cuando los
talibanes estuvieron en el poder en su
primer régimen en los años 90 se
convirtió Afganistán en un santuario de
terroristas y Desde allí se planeó el
atentado contra las Torres Gemelas en
Nueva York Bueno hay que pensar que qué
puede ocurrir en el futuro si nos
olvidamos de Afganistán y no nos
implicamos de alguna manera para poner
freno a este radicalismo religioso